I just wanted to make a quick reminder
that we have an open problem session
tomorrow at 3:15 thank you for joining
us for the the only panel for this
workshop unlike previous workshops so
the panel is and statistical Theory
privacy and data analysis on the TVs for
us in the room you can see actually who
our panelists are and I will just take a
minute to introduce I introduce everyone
and perhaps instead of going in the
order there appear and the a screen
which was alphabetical or start from our
guest of honor I've been you who is
distinguished faculty in Department of
Statistics electrical engineering
computer science here at Berkeley and
she does not work on price has not
worked on privacy but I thought it was
very important to have somebody let's
say from the outside our community to
give us perspective on science of data
analysis and how does this fit with were
comprise John du chí faculty at Stanford
University you just heard him speak and
I guess as he described himself he works
on many many different things and has
electric in interest so I'll just leave
it at that
you Sheng Wang is the assistant
professor at UC Santa Barbara he's he
works on machine learning and data
privacy as well how much time care is
the research at IBM many of you of
course know him mostly works on I guess
here at computer science but both
privacy problems and algorithmic
fairness and Anand sir want a professor
drug turfs University and statistics
sorry first electrical engineering but
also with affiliate appointment in
statistic computer science
he works also on machine learning
optimization and statistical problems
and I all before we continue I also want
to give us a really hand of applause
- Anand whoo
really despite having worship cool
organizers really organized this
workshop so please join me at least so
we have offered to anyone who is
contacting who is watching remotely to
send any questions via email and here
you don't want to raise your hand you
can also send an email let's try to
monitor my email so um what is the I
mean what are the main questions for the
panel um we were interested in hearing
or for families to start telling it's a
little bit first about from their point
of view what do they mean by science of
data analysis because I think we have
different communities here and it would
be great to hear what we mean by that so
and then the question because I can
important question that we're interested
in addressing is how can we bridge the
gap between theoretical concepts in both
computer science and statistics with
they make it make these theoretical
ideas turn into real applications and
reality so how do we go from theory to
methodology we also provided panelists
with two concrete examples just to help
them perhaps think about a little bit
more about the science of data analysis
but we would love to hear from them and
for everyone else more broadly than just
of the concept of statistical
significance and adaptive data analysis
the reason why we chose these two as
examples because there's actually an
ongoing debate in the synthesis
community right now on how to report
statistical significance and this is a
very very important topic right now and
of course there's a lot of work and in
both communities
any social sciences and other areas of
science on adaptive data analysis so
these are two examples and I said we
welcome other ideas and other examples
so I will start with Lucci as father
maybe being you know okay so it's not
opinion an expert's first run expert
first and now and also didn't want to
start first but I'm gonna put him on the
spot what do we mean by that we are
general respective oh I guess I do work
with scientists so that's I guess that's
important to think about I mean we talk
about science we're talking about the
creation of knowledge or you know we at
least pretend like we're talking about
the creation of knowledge of some
problems in epistemology and I think a
lot of times as a electrical engineer
I'm not afraid to call myself an
engineer we work on the engineering of
data analysis so we work on saying oh
here's an algorithm let me better but
that's not the methodology unless these
algorithms are used and especially in
complex working with complex scientific
data which may or may which may which
may be live individuals which is where
the privacy comes in the methodology is
quite complicated and we don't
necessarily always acknowledge that when
we claim make claims about the
algorithms that we designed because they
couldn't be used in some context there's
a big pipe lines of them
there's complicated issues around so
it's not a matter of to start swapping
out you know this test or that
regression for a new one and I think
we have to think we're think about
science like a bigger picture than
individual methods so it's a very broad
question so what I would think of as the
science of data analysis is the process
of taking data which was collected
somehow and turning it into true and
meaningful conclusions whereby true I
mean organization or having some method
for quantifying and understanding
uncertainty is always present but
meaningful I mean either it's
interesting or useful or solve some
problem somewhere and science is just
coming out with various methods of doing
this yeah I very much agree with Thomas
and I just wanted to add like one more
point so I think the science of data
analysis should also include the data
collection phase so so you decide what
kind of data you collect and how to
collect the most meaningful data to to
answer the kind of questions that you're
asking
besides that I agree with that and can
you I'm sorry I can you also comment I
maybe we can go back around like how do
you feel your definition fits within the
privacy or context or with privacy but
we can come back maybe to that if you
want yeah yeah bye I think I guess
social responsibility other kind of
constraints privacy and the fairness are
the new desiderata that we definitely
needs to take care of so that we can do
things more responsibly because ethics
is the important aspect of more than
science of data analysis in my opinion
I have a weird riff on AI but but maybe
that's not so for me it's really the
whole iterative process of starting from
problem population and together which
domain scientist and discuss design data
collecting is really something I'll call
empirical rigor that we all have to
define collectively either data
collection and that's probably already
have privacy issues there and then you
go to data cleaning which is something
we do and we put under the rock that you
can lose profits you can add profits it
depends on how you do it
and then there's data visualizations and
then to the modeling stage people care
about and then you do post hoc analysis
to visualization interpretation and then
you might collect new data and reiterate
the problem population so for me it's
this iterative process of stitute
investigation which George Parkes
aesthetician Daphne wrote about in the
60s right now how data science lifecycle
and this particular cycle my group and
my son particularly advocating stability
considerations for our problem
formulation and I think differential
privacy section follow stability in some
sense you basically try to make things
control and it's really about solving
problems I think we have to focus the
science of maintenance a small problem
I'm solving he said just stay down there
you know it's rally to a problem with
our problem I don't think they don't
send meaningful
okay so this is sort of a bit of a
tangent that I've been you know sort of
watching you know machine learning and
statistics morph into data science which
then morphed into AI and brains over the
past like 10 years and I've been sort of
thinking just broadly about education
and how that interplays with this kind
of like AI is everything so there's a
recent article by Mike Jordan called AI
the revolution hasn't happened yet
I don't know if you guys have read this
but but it's it's it's a really
interesting article and sort of the
point of it is that that clarity of
thought and discipline is extremely
important so you know you think okay
there's tensorflow now right so Google
is tensorflow and you can anyone can
download this and type go and Python or
whatever the command is you c++ vitaly
but but but you know it's not you know
you asked like how did we get to the
point where we can actually do this
analysis and build these systems and
things like this and there's huge
amounts of investment in kind of you
know numerical optimization you open any
machine learning textbook it starts with
basic concepts and statistics and
probability right and so so for me i
mean i mean for those of us in the
academy or in industry you know thinking
about where do we actually invest in
terms of providing you know funding
investment things like this for for
education and things like this I think
it's really important that we not call
just everything AI and AI is gonna solve
everything it's like what it what are
the actual meaningful disciplines that
underpin these subjects I mean I know
that's not the topic exactly this
session but
yes that's a really - signs of data
analysis how does that relate to science
of data analysis well I mean if you if
you if you open up the new york times
there are editorials every week by very
famous people like the head of scripts
right this guy is an md he wrote an
editorial in the NY team that you know
the scripts not scripts what's the
medical listen to the scripts the
medical institute what's that what's the
medical institute don't
sorry scripts to see what's the matter
ones that didn't salt maybe salt yeah so
the head of the Salk Institute sorry
thank you and so he's an MD and he
writes this editorial that says let AI
choose your diet but he bases it he
bases his entire article on a paper that
was in cell biology in 2014 by Erin
Siegel who measured like glycemic
responses and gut microbiomes and flora
in like a million people or something
insane like this right but it wasn't a I
who decided to run this experiment
wasn't AI who decided what to measure I
mean there were just fundamental
biological statistical questions and the
method they used to fit the models they
were using was a gradient boosting which
was in the annals of statistics in 2001
right because that was what were the
best you know none of this is AI but
like calling it a I sort of obscures
like all of the deep scientific rigor
that went into this and to me this is a
little distressing at the head of like a
major Research Institute is writing
about this in the NYT that I mean this
is a guy who will influence in you know
science policy in this country or at
least at major universities and I think
all of us it but whose us to be very
clear like you know I mean I mean one
thing that I love about like the privacy
literature general is like there's a
very clear demand for rigor if you say
something's private it better damn well
be private right like there has to be
approved associated to that which is
great but I think yeah you know just
broadly as we think about like data
science AI all this stuff moving
together it's important that we nail
down what we're doing and why it matters
and how we did it I kind of agree with
what you said but the question is do we
control the use of a cavalry
that's the problem with the whole
society into actually hyping it right do
I have the power with a new name yeah
not bad I'm a data scientist now not a
statistician because those stations are
boring I feel like what you're saying is
that AI is not the sciences yeah that's
part that's part of it but I also think
I mean it's I actually really like the
idea of like saying there's a science of
data analysis and being rigorous about
what it is but I I don't know I happy I
don't know the answer your questions
like words aren't just a sceptic labels
that mean nothing though right I mean
they have academic don't all actually
defining meaning that's the problem and
you can leave it to statistics we
probably you know a lot of statistical
idea being called machine learning lies
yeah I so done by academic people too I
guess actually want to pick up on things
that both of you said one was about
working this domain scientists I mean
the other was sort of about how your
point about language one thing is that
maybe for the outside and I'm on the
outside of it you know you think of
statistics as being like oh there's a
there's a formalism for statistics but
then if you look at actual statistical
practice is like a collection of a so
some of the Associated methodologies
that are you know kind of patched
together there's like a morass of like
what people doing in very different in
different fields extremely different and
not just like what kind of test they do
but like you know what how they handle
the data and all this other thing and it
I guess one question I have and I'm not
sure is like is there is there a one
type of rigor rigorous methodology that
we should then do try as an educator so
I guess the
it was a little education then we then
say okay now this is the right way to do
think there's one right way to do things
and then we should try to shoehorn the
existing statistical practice you know
Corral effect not not like in a fascist
way but you know sort of progressive Li
as we go along kind of way to you know
get people to talk work to start doing
doing it in a more with more empirical
rigor have you tried to do things like a
lot of lines through teaching because
when I agree with you the after I've get
my PhD practice for 30 years it's not
easy to for somebody else from outside
to really get on top of it so that's why
we haven't evolved is three principles
like face if you don't wish to learning
and stability and for the this semester
I'm teaching a mission learning class
and I came out with his three circle
idea kind of hinges on your second
question about how do we relate
algorithm to see reality and I realized
that traditional statistic we kind of
put it together future reality today's
reality repair the data and algorithms
so I couldn't start from three circles
and say the algorithm is a mental
construct exist in your brain in
mathematical signal so you have to
bridge the gap from reality to
algorithms through documentation both
English narratives and quantitative
narratives and visualization to bridge
the gap and if you subscribe to our pcs
framework you have the document which
reproducible codes and narrative to back
up assumptions explain why using certain
ways so I think that's a step forward to
bridge the gap but if we teach
everything and see if they're always
together we have a probability model and
we do maximum likelihood and we have
shoot your data from the same other you
don't want to do with these questions
but I agree that education with shown
that it's going to be a step to teach
this rico ng by this room
so I think if I can interject so
basically what you just described is
described a set of steps and your I
think I understood you correctly you're
advocating for the transparency of those
steps exactly statistical analysis and
also have high-level principles which
you apply like physics
hopefully that when the message changed
by this high-level philosophical
principles don't change like check for
reality while we teach classes we don't
people just ran models because I ever
worry about checking for reality there
should be the first bit you need to have
some way of checking reality prediction
or not okay so let me see if I can also
bring this back to the question of
privacy right because we want to see how
these concepts relate to privacy so one
you know at least differential privacy
is advocating for transparencies so it
seems that at least the form of let's
say differential privacy or it's a
formal privacy methodology advocates for
transparency and that should go along
with what you're advocating in terms of
transparency of persons sophistical
process right now this question of check
for reality I would like to learn a
little bit more about this because I
think this is very important and we're
starting to implement formal privacy
methods in a large scale in including
senses some of the industries right so
what do you mean by checking for reality
and again I would anyone else come and
pitch in I just thought maybe this is a
lot so here would be like I think T P we
have done a lot of theorem see I'm not
on top of everything but seems to me I
like to see a lot of empirical studies
and bring social scientists in and to
apply data already exist in the past and
differential privacy to it and see
whether the analysis could be done by
because this is transparency versus a
crazy for analysis downstream right for
the analysis past you don't hide you
don't mask anything but for promise you
to seduce the trade-off it in
transparency versus accuracy of of
downstream amount
so what one of the most important
feature about differential parents is
transparency and it's about how
universal it is applicable so so so
suppose you say an algorithm is
absolutely virtually private then no
matter which data sets you substitute
into this house and it's always going to
be even on differential attacks but but
one thing I think that it's extremely
important when you try to apply that in
practice which this back to this point
on transparency and trying to ground
your algorithm to the reality is to
understand in every scenario what that
epsilon actually means for this
particular setting it really depends on
like epsilon is an upper bound on the
privacy loss and it really depends on
how crude that upper bound is for every
for every instance separately and I
don't think we have enough well defined
procedures to answer this kind of
questions you know each application
[Music]
so the Iranian great privacy into it I
mean there's one sort of view the
privacy is opposed to utility but I
don't think we shouldn't restrict
ourselves to that view because first off
privacy and privacy preserving
technologies are also a way to open up
new sources of data which reach and also
there's the the recent line of work and
adaptive data analysis which shows that
there actually some side benefits of
accessing data and eventually manner
first off it enforces good data hygiene
you're you're not gonna be going peeing
or fishing for stuff you're accessing
your database but also more formally
there are generalization guarantees that
are differential privacy so you should
view privacy is also potentially being
hand-in-hand I mean I guess a thing I'm
working on it is in fact being able to
tell that somebody who has a data set
that we will access your data settle
need a differential a private way is an
incentive and actually you can see that
people are willing to participate in the
research collaboration because we're
doing that so that's that's certainly
true the but the challenge of setting
reasonable value of epsilon is a very
opaque to me as well and you know I can
do it there like some sort of cross
validation but that I'm eating up my
president budget like trying to set
epsilon V across Foundation so I'm like
you know becomes a I think we I mean I
like to think of the scientific methods
you know I have a hypothesis don't
encode collect data and then I check my
hypothesis but that is never the way it
works and I just end up having the data
that I have right so the works that
we're in fourth grade I think yeah once
I weighed fourth grade right so
so so I think you know having having a
holdout I mean a reasonable holdout and
that kind of thing is is really great
but in some scenarios maybe that's not
easy easy to come by
with or without privacy so
so I think somehow you know so I'm very
receptive of these ideas of okay if we
have privacy that Matt enforces a kind
of stability we know what the stability
is super important in different data
analysis
let's but let's let's ask a slightly
different question like okay what about
you know industrial applications you
know Google Apple Facebook yes
everything right so there that at least
right now there seems to be some kind of
tension between the kind of privacy
protections and services provided right
like it's very useful for me my phone
can you know predict the next word I'm
gonna type because and you know what I
type is presumably different from what
you guys so I can so like a local model
to me that's really good is maybe kind
of useful right and so uh I I mean I
don't know but maybe I guess one
question is you know is there some way
we can kind of combine some sort of like
best practices like you know not letting
perfect be the enemy of the good right
like if if somebody says ok and says ok
well we're gonna try to do this
privately and then we say ok well that's
not private enough it's no good then you
know then you're like well actually
we're gonna just sell all the data they
can't Bridgend let it go so whatever
right like that's not where we want to
end up I guess and and so I don't know
how this tension should play out like
there are some like I guess Cynthia are
you involved in ss1 yeah social science
1 and so I think I think some of these
tensions are rising here like my
understanding is that different
researchers are going to be given some
epsilon budget or something like this
and then expect it not to collaborate
together to break things or something
like that is that not the case so we
know what's happening yet there is an
ons question I don't actually know
there may be a definition of we but I
cannot say that I know what's going on
there measure a house record I've been
trying to get data from UK biobank oh
sorry I'm just so so hard
so I've already started about it do you
like so you see doesn't like whatever
does that Duncan will have to sign missi
pyle bank and they will signed a
separate thing but just so much work to
even get and now I finally got
permission I have to add my team that's
another few weeks so I don't know I
don't understand the privacy aspect that
magical record look do people here
understand what's going on with the
magical records what's going on there
English people or not they just make
arbitrary rules they definitely have
privacy concerned that's why they asked
me to sign tons of documents I don't
understand why but I'm just doing it
just because I have to do it as I know
the the medical record privacy at least
in the u.s. is a total disaster
because they say and you're good I'm not
an expert on the night there but I
thought that HIPAA even laws so that
there's like a list of 16 identifiers
that you're expected to remove and once
those are removed that's supposed to be
treated we know what's going on in the
magical community I'm here privatized in
some sense yeah alright well they don't
do a great job of well I mean actually
so I I don't know I mean I know some day
I know some data sets which have been
released under safe harbor but I don't
know any I don't I don't think there's
like a collection of like all of these
data sets at least under safe harbor
you're not a surgeon
so a guy I the degree to which you know
although it is possible under the law to
do something like this I don't know to
what degree it's you know posted yeah
posted publicly like I sold in the way
that you suggest I mean I'm pessimistic
to look I'm gonna sell
the picture painting is a bit a bit more
nefarious than then I don't know if is
warranted I guess I mean if they can
make money selling it then they have a
great incentive not to put it on
publicly there are also medical data
sets that are available for free it's
kind of scary I think one thing we're
we're missing also the press of be
informed consent process to talk about
the data collection process so sometimes
people have consented to have that
information shared knowing yeah of
course you don't import you don't fund
there's no like they don't post post
consent their post consent informing
there's I think we're kind of far away
from science actually I don't think we
are because many of researchers actually
worked with with health medical data and
especially you talk about precision
medicine these days there's a lot of
effort put into that so I think we're
not far from it but before we continue I
want to make sure that anyone in the
audience tastes here if you have any
questions or something you would like to
ask our panelists otherwise I will
continue with what questions I have well
please good yeah so I like science
so in data science there's a lot of like
you know if you do like hypothesis
testing and stuff there's like husband
tonic results these were a real high on
but then when you want to include
privacy this thing needs to hold all the
time right so how do you sort of make
amends
like privacy all the time utility as
methodically how do you bring that
together I mean now ultimately you want
the most precise result for the fine
example for both accuracy and privacy
that's not always easy and that's the
reason why people go by asymptotic
because then like for much larger class
of problems that you can actually
calibrate say the type 1 error to
precisely what you want like even doing
that with differential piracy is the
challenge and I think the community is
still working there are two but I guess
like something like papers like you'll
have like a level of significance right
and then like that'll be the determinant
to whether you like a drunk goes out
there right but these are sort of based
on asymptotic results even though
translating a p-value yeah yeah I mean
there are nonparametric ways you can do
things you can do permutation test which
works for finite sample all you need is
exchange ability for full confidence
interval you can do construction yeah
that's more after 1830
I mean so asymptotics are and are very
elegant and nice because they give us
the right constants right yeah it's like
here's the constant it's one yeah right
and I mean part of your answer it's you
know you can go read Adams paper on
asymptotics and stochastic estimator
statistical estimation with privacy then
you get to smush them together but I
think another answer is that there's a
there's a movement and this isn't really
dealing with privacy question but
there's a movement in statistics to
trying to develop new flavors of
asymptotics okay so which is to say you
know I have a dimension D or like I'm
gonna do di policies tests and I have a
sample size and you know D over N goes
to a constant so they're scaling
together and this is a very different
asymptotic regime than what we had in
the past than it seems actually often to
make better predictions he's for a lot
of problems in what classical on
societies give us but the tools to
develop these things are extremely
sophisticated right now and and and and
there is some hope that maybe this helps
address some of these issues of yeah
false discoveries and things like this
because you say you know okay we have we
have our classical bar for any
Corrections we have our like FDR control
false discovery rate control and things
like this but potentially a new version
of asymptotics where we actually
understand like the scaling of the
ratios of things and then the exact
constants and those scenarios may help
us beyond this end but that the examples
here are right now quite sophisticated
and the analyses are fairly bespoke and
really tailored to the problems at hand
and we'll see where it goes I think it's
a very promising area but right now we
don't totally understand it I know
so I think that anything in the room
actually lots of times unless you have
extensive randomization actually we do
that's why we use probability statements
is sexually nothing is the first order
problem then worry about how to
interpret p-value where the p-values
calculate write that open any day that
people just start putting basic ID
probability models and that has
consequences downstream huge ways that I
think actually I think this is the
biggest problem why you don't have
Express randomization that Jesus have
data you just start throwing models and
probabilistic to Annette and we start
interpreting asymptotics which is a
probability model and we interpret
p-value of course asymptotic result it's
really weak emergence right it's really
not really strong approximation why was
your read of the normal curve ten to the
minus eight that's beyond me you cannot
trust normal curve less small tail right
you should go with much deviation but we
don't so so all this that but that's a
second-order problems actually when we
start populating properties among other
one there's no explicit randomization
that worries me most these days that you
sometimes did you only have one data
said you really don't need random
variable if you need random variable
you're really thinking there's another
situation where since could I be
observed as a realization of the same
random variable and if implicit it's
assuming stability right it's another
physical situation they can put two data
as two realizations if you cannot even
think about another realization why do
you need random variable we should just
start with your fixed a I mean I've been
teaching for 25 years without blink with
X minus R excellent starting my lecture
lab but the last five years are housing
and I don't introduce random arab until
I served into the semester and be very
very careful but how do you do in prints
if you don't know some kind
well I would just make it transparent
that's in our pcs framework for my group
we call perturbation intervals so you do
just perturbations through subsampling
and that's what you get right if you
make sense of it maybe it's too useful
then I'm not using the properties of
framework is not just the same that's
exact you were to uh perturb the data
this is how I did it and here's the
perturbation it's kind of useless but I
think it's more honest than throwing a
probability model without any backing
I mean this seems more like a minimal
assumption oh no time axis to need a
probability moldos I'm not trying to say
if you cannot Jesse probability models
I'll just say that's how it's kind of
like rhythmic I'll call that a greased
modeling you just preserve the data this
way it's a cold and that's what the
difference is you've got it it's a bit
like how you would evaluate robustness
of an engineering system like you I get
a couple of cars and it's a systematic
way that's why that's what kind of draw
distinction between somehow science and
engineering you know that's an
engineering approach and questions it
doesn't create one question I have is do
we do we doing create knowledge we learn
something true about the world when we
do that and I think we do learn
something true about the box that I've
been here and how it behaves yeah we
always you say here's our properties
aversion we learn something about the
parameter where Y is the probability
distribution woven don't discuss right
yeah I definitely do that I'm just as
skewed as everything else right
forgive him but I think I wanna dive
back to I think this question actually
came yesterday why Poisson distribution
was the right distribution for a dream
Katrina asked the question on if she's
around or not there was some creation of
synthetic data and this is the question
that we do often ask us that the six as
well will be model right so but we do
four I guess to simplify our life often
make assumptions and believe that that
certain model is the right model and but
this is a very important question and
it's important question for privacy as
well I think I don't think that there
may be relevant for this audience time
to to what being you just said in terms
of you know not actually calculating P
values based on probabilistic model by
actually using perturbations we're
starting to teach in our interest
sophistic score PSA's you know how what
is really you know a p-value but from a
perturbation perspective and and
simulations and randomizations rather
than thinking specifically about
probabilistic models and I think when
you speak about randomization
perturbations I think those ideas are
also there is close link with with
privacy concepts and and so there's
another Avenue but I think Phil had a
question so I think a common concern
that I've seen expressed within sort of
the external community of experts that
are not privacy people but are
interested in using the end data is sort
of a reasonable concern which is given
that you passed the data before
publication through a rigorous privacy
mechanism satisfying DP or some other
form overrides a definition how can they
a be able to sort of plate with the data
in an exploratory sense to sort of find
pattern that they think are interesting
but weren't about queries that were
anticipated ahead of time and I had a B
but I've sort of Capri on what it was I
suppose the the really a key part of
this question is sort of the obvious way
to deal with this is try to target a
really large class of queries by
generating micro data but I think with
my impression at Lee is just that that
is very difficult to do and I think
there are also some theoretical results
suggesting method
my heart and that's I'm curious if you
all have any thoughts about how
differentially private sort of
exploratory data analysis can be sort of
improved be easier and scaled up to
handle large groups of users externally
first my pushback that people have been
cleaning data in whatever way we don't
know and then they have no problem doing
data exploration
so I finally strange there you have a
very systematic way adding noise and
they have a problem too if you have a
problem we cleaned it out we don't talk
about it and then we have no problem to
needy a up the data cleaning so so I
don't see why people have problem it's
that that actually you know exactly what
you did to the data that you do
visualization so I think they do to just
you know the data cleaning this is an
extremely important problem that risk so
so this this kopacz to I think to the
very heart of the science of data
analysis in that how how do we allow how
do we enable scientists to actually look
at the data play with the data and do
the kind of interactive data analysis
port or a data analysis in a way that
they are used to in the new era when we
are expecting things to be more rigorous
and to have provable guarantees in terms
of the privacy of the individuals I
think this is really the very heart of
the problem that people
so either you know spin to put on this
this question is should people really be
playing with the data I know there's a
lot of debate about it analysis about
key hacking and the potential that
people are basically doing things that
they shouldn't be doing and then once
they start from that point into a data
analysis the end result is no longer
valid so one way to sort of respond to
the question with another question which
is you know what sort of exploratory
data analysis okay I mean it's some
folks in there there there's a some
folks have started to try to build like
database systems that allow you to do
this right I guess this is like pink and
I'm sure there are others that I just
don't remember that privacy integrated
query languages pink but you know you
could imagine basically like an R shell
and you implement say all that women are
some subset of the commands in our base
commands in R and each time you call one
of them it actually just ones the
differential private thing under the
hood and it spits out the result right
you could you could certainly imagine
dream pretty far from there I mean
potentially maybe maybe you say look we
can do this and we're not actually gonna
provide that greater privacy guarantees
because we'll just let you keep noodling
around with this data until you're done
and you know so epsilon your epsilon is
475 or whatever but hey you know maybe
it's better than nothing or maybe we're
just like no that's a terrible idea I
don't know but but but essentially
something you know starting to build
like basically like our Julia or one of
these kind of you know interpreted
statistical data sciences languages with
some privacy stuff and put my vehicle
way to do this Adam
but I didn't want to stop that I wanted
to ask a different touched off okay and
apparently you don't even much the only
people the audience don't need a mic
coastal okay so do you wanna so maybe
I'll just make one comment the the one
article or our series of article things
that we sent from the Americans decision
we share the link with everybody on
reporting statistical significance there
was an interesting proposal there where
they said okay so we don't want they
call to Mai's decisions or discretize
decisions of statistical significance
any longer but perhaps what we should be
doing is everyone should be doing
exploratory data analysis reporting
their exploratory data analysis until
from only exploratory data analysis we
converge to something that looks like a
strong hypothesis then that actually
could be tested it's just to add in
terms of exploratory data analysis
important and you can look at it from
any different perspective and
perspectives and I think this is
something that we as a privacy community
you really have to think about very
carefully about how we can incorporate
or develop tools to allow practitioners
to continue to be able to do exploratory
data analysis even if it's with
differentially private data and there
many reasons for that good Adam
I guess is gonna raise a somewhat
related point but it's different which
is about sort of reproducibility and the
question was you know if we want to move
to a world where researchers are very
careful about what's what they publish
in their papers how do we this is phil
was mentioning this earlier you know how
do we find bugs that we like inspect the
process we can inspect we can expect
their code like that's not so hard but
you know going back to making sure they
didn't there weren't a stupid mistakes
made at various points is like much
harder if you don't if you can't expose
the entire pipeline and clear and so the
question is sort of what what
infrastructure is needed you need a
place where people deposit their data
and then there's like you know so that
there's some verification that what
they're what is in their paper actually
came from running the code they claim
they've read proof is there you know are
there any good solutions to the SMU and
how do we put also stop it from
researchers from using it to prevent
reproduction right to make a you know
harder to reproduce the result there's
some work in the statistics of Dylan
foster at Penn has tried to get folks to
throw free not site-19 posted
no not Dean Foster either doing small
upends nuts yes real small sorry too
many too many but he's trying to get
folks to sort of pre-register like
basically treat observational studies
where you're kind of looking for cobble
things as almost like he's trying to set
of things where you can pre-register the
studies you're going to do it some kind
of Clearinghouse and things like this so
there's movements you none of them are
gonna have like zero knowledge proof
sore anything like this that you're
certifying okay
doing but you sort of there's some level
of trust that somebody pre registers
then they're going to do the analysis
that they said they're going to do so
there's bits and pieces of this coming
up but there's nothing I don't think
there's some global model at the entity
which is certifying this I mean I think
part of the problem is that a lot of
researchers are incentives so they keep
their data set themselves because this
is a gold mine
that anyone else so how do we set up the
incentives it'll be great to have a
central repository repository where all
the data gets its place and other people
can come along and replicate studies
before other studies but incentives the
real question but I think you're like it
turn those like pas is requiring data
repositories but you're saying yeah
people just come with the excuse that
it's private so we don't need to share
it no no they're becoming very very
serious these days like two three years
ago similar people got away with it and
weights up in favour we have
collaborators who really fast to share
the days so I think they get any very
serious so that's one way to do it that
nothing I'd she's also
I think Adams question was like about it
was more about like you know how do you
validate the methods that are being used
less right I mean how do you you're sure
that what people will say that they're
doing what they're doing and I guess one
way that site rise to do this is by
limiting what people can do right in
some sense it says good pre asked us all
the questions when you register to the
data set with side since I'm here only
here because so they'll couldn't make it
so this is really great
but but but is it mean does that solve
some of it essentially then you know
you're trusting the person I implements
that system that the analyses that they
the this subset of analyses they did
we're done in the right way and so I
guess do you build on that and I guess
one question might be do you build on
that starting point expand that out or
you look you know thinking about
something a bit more open-ended hey I
think that that kind of that addresses
some some aspects but I somehow I feel
this probably like a bigger issue there
well first of all you don't you can't
force everybody to use like the same
well
but yeah just in general how do you it's
not even about like malicious use of the
system people maliciously trying to
prevent reproducibility but just like if
if things are differentially private how
do you you know think of that bugs in
there judge number generators and all
sorts of stuff that isn't apparent from
the code it just becomes much harder to
verify what's going on coding to only
run once a real data I think one way
it's really like when people in
undergrad your education part data a try
students start using ipython book to
small habit-forming that will help about
different groups take a protocol to make
sure things are reproducible so I think
that's eventually probably help I
already instead of like training
students you know more reproducible way
so in terms of sharing data there are
issues associated with forcing
researchers to share their their their
data for instance suppose the data are
about human subjects and sharing the
data publicly will expose the subjects
to privacy risks different data sets and
then figure out who's who including
those with terminal diseases and so on
there they're gonna be ways to do this
in the more secure and private fashion
gets you through checking's
precisely whether this paper can be
reproduced I mean I think my question
back to the van with regarding the PNAS
if they're enforcing this rule of data
sharing I was actually exactly when
asked what happened situation that
almost
he's trying to publish the paper and
they clearly cannot share some of the
original data right or in the case of
the medical studies like what is PNAS
doing actually in that case do you know
I think they probably just said then if
you don't want our policies they
basically probably don't take your paper
it's your choice they were really hard
on us because we saw paper very similar
data from four years ago people didn't
share right this time when we submitted
their basic your asses
we said we share some secondary data
that wasn't good enough it was basic
they were ready not to even take off
that right submission that creates
another problem which is for anything in
part the the scientific world right and
and and learning and modelling new data
and learning the results of them so so
there's like type 1 type 2 error rise
entry though so I mean I'm just saying
that they're taking a very hard line so
maybe one one additional point to make
is that potentially it could be that the
the journal or some some third party is
the one that runs the the code on the
data I think it's there's also that uh
what appears in the paper and then you
have this third party which is actually
you can hopefully can trust the Bay
indeed ran the code that they were told
to rob they also helped trust in the
whole system
yeah on that I did talk to nature a
couple years ago about when I was
pushing stability so they were very open
about if that if I write a stability
check side and they will tell happy to
say that if they passed a certificate
they were happy to consider that by they
know the random so that's like the idea
if consulted I'm some sort reduce how
the reproducibility check and the
journals probably well kind of respect
that and they type I didn't want to
write them but you know it's some third
party that yeah holding the data and
also running ho people has submitted a
the subject to something random
[Music]
okay so I'm just when if you everyone a
chance to kind of then maybe come back
to to how we started so certain
decisions have defined statistics as the
science of learning from data that are
measuring controlling and communicating
uncertainty we talk in this semester
here and in this workshop we speak a lot
about uncertainty and so I just you know
any thoughts and comments again how the
privacy fits with particular these that
finish no statistics and you know data
science I think fits within this
definition we just came from a specific
little chair so if you just want to wrap
up there say something about that
so uncertainty and how we deal with it I
mean yes there's ditions are the the
masters of dealing with certainly
there's no trouble dealing with
differential privacy that's something
you said earlier but so but but you feel
that the the he's the formal concepts of
privacy coming along again I'm trying to
be more general than just differential
privacy it is about you know uncertainty
and that should play along well with
statistics right but you know maybe
there are senior I understand then you
have more fits more uncertainty it's not
a good thing
but I do think it does fit into the
whole picture office I then also say you
know the answer source of uncertainty
have to deal with that you need to
understand that need to analyze it
hopefully you're actually gonna get less
uncertainty because you not have access
to more dicta I mean I guess okay if we
go back if we don't like bins you know
proposal for like essentially basing a
lot of the first part of statistics on
just you know perturbation analysis and
stability there then what's interesting
to me actually is that then you have the
output of a differential a private
algorithm that actually comes from a
probabilistic model there the
probabilistic models correct as we've
made it we made it happen so all the
tools that we have for inference there
could be applied may be fruitfully you
know just the old methodology could be
apply fruitfully you know the privacy
part is just like our old models again
you know because now we've replaced our
original probabilistic modeling with
something that isn't based on
probability that's very weird and
speculative so another science fiction
of statistics it's about harnessing
probability distributions and how do you
make inferences from a sample data to
the underlying parameter and
differential privacy is like I think one
of the only cases where the statistical
theorems about particular probability
distributions can be directly applied
without worrying about the assumptions
is wrong because we generated this
additional randomness and so it so this
is one of the theme of this workshop I
think it is really important people
should do this more to to use
statistical tools to have actually
capture and harness this additional
randomness from from from from
differential privacy so that we can make
more valid inference I feel like I
should I should say
Computers I would say that it's there's
a tree though sometimes for privacy you
have to increase in certainty and I
think we very interesting for the
community posts this is in privacy how
many to understand a few canonical cases
in context to see how this trade-off
plays out and and then generalize from
there so other area can borrow pretty
empirical experience to do this exact Oh
like more practical trade-offs
okay last question thank you sorry so
the discussion about other sources of
randomness kind of caught my attention
because something that's been on my mind
for a while is necessarily really isn't
relevant to the project I actually
worked on the decennial census because
sort of ostensibly they're the the
reasonably snow sampling here but for
every other product a census essentially
there there is substantial sampling
error I'm as well as a number of others
which is very measurement error
non-response air etc etc something I
found very interesting and sort of
digging through atoms but blog posts is
that there's sort of a secrecy of the
sample style and what the amplification
theorem there that under so mild
assumptions we beacon beacon sort of
abused to take advantage of some of this
extra noise to sort of amplify or reduce
the privacy lost budget that we're
actually expending in practice and some
of the survey based products that seems
really important to me because it's
going to be very difficult with the
sample sizes in those products if we
don't take advantage of that extra sort
of noise structure I think to get up
salons that are going to make anyone
happy when either side of sort of the
discussion about where epsilon should
fall but I guess I was wondering it's I
think it's clear to me and I'm hopefully
others agree that there needs to be more
work of that kind because those results
are very special and they only apply to
very particular cases right now but I
was also kind of curious with all of
these other sources of randomness that
are floating around is there any
random structure we might possibly
plausibly take advantage of to sort of
have similar amplification theorems it
could be in measurement error it could
be an imputation air--so indication
processes often involve the nature
contribute there sometimes they make
things worse as sort of adding some of
our collaborators have discovered
picking and non-response area or
whatever but if there's other
opportunities for these kinds of
amplification theorems I think they
could be a really valuable source of
privacy ahmen practicality so I was
wondering if you all have any thoughts
on that question so how does random
projection relate to procedures that's
another way people add a lot of random
is used Johnson in the house transform
its preservative ever since or-or-or I
wrote that paper so yeah thanks for the
question so so I think we need to
distinguish between the randomness as we
can use force and the kind of randomness
that we assume so for every assumption
that we make we can make use of that and
into a sketch calculation and figure out
the corresponding implication of that in
privacy but but that's that's not real
at least in the in in adversarial world
but but in terms of substance in terms
of survey sampling those are really
things that we can we can we can you
force and we can we can talk about how
the implement implication of that in the
accuracy utility parts you need a
trade-off set that's being deployed in a
census she would kind of rather not use
measurement error or say but but yeah I
think is that from the worst-case view
of the world I'd rather not well I could
we don't control we don't control the
measurement error in the same way so I
think that's the Heart Association about
modeling like you know if I if I go to
my electrical engineering friends and I
say that code you got a differential
privacy look great all the noise is
Gaussian anyway there's always noise at
your system so everything is already
private which is not you know and then
you know like yes it's bogus but the
wise I focused because we just assumed
that the noise was guess
but so many assembly error for example
right you know the size of the error and
my kitchen privacy please
I think I would have a hard time getting
up getting impassive reviewers I think
imputation is something that's very
interesting because potentially it's
actually bad for privacy like my day
that gets replicated to watch it on to
other people maybe that's that's harmful
to my privacy so it's also danger that
some of these processes which we might
think are good for privacy are actually
getting some people better privacy but
also hurting others any last comments
thank you very much for for your
insights and your comments as a girl has
been perfect for your participation and